it's great to be joined today by Thomas
Wood who's an assistant professor of
political science at the Ohio State
University also co-author of the
forthcoming book enchanted America it's
so great to talk to you today and I
can't think of a better time to talk
about the issue of conspiratorial
thinking and conspiracy theories we have
sort of this coming together of a long
history of decades of conspiracy
theories in America we have Q and on and
we also have conspiracy theorists like
Alex Jones being thrown off of some of
the prominent social platforms on the
Internet so so let's maybe start very
very broadly what is included under the
idea of conspiratorial thought and
conspiracy theories is it just stuff
like paul mccartney died and a similarly
sounding left-handed bass player has
been filling in for him ever since or
like what how wide is the umbrella of
conspiratorial thought so first off
thanks thanks having me on i guess
eric and i we approached thinking about
conspiracy theories as any narratives
which is all-encompassing which explains
a broad number of political events and
is supported by little or no external
evidence and so that is a useful enough
conspiracy theory to account for things
like okay you've alluded to so the idea
that Paul McCartney has suffered an
accident sometime in the 1960s and and
an artist has been imitating Paul in
recent decades through to more damaging
conspiracy theories the idea that
shadowy groups control us finance the
idea that the 9/11 terror attacks were
planned by it by elements with inside
the US government for political purposes
and so the one sort of thread that we
can use to join up all those different
accounts is there's really no or very so
weak evidence for any of these accounts
the absence of evidence is not really
enough to disabuse its followers from
believing in these knots another
characteristic that seems common is that
an absence of evidence or an apparent
absence of evidence is often taken to be
evidence because it's part of the
conspiracy in other words either there
doesn't seem to be evidence because the
evidence is being covered up by the
perpetrators of the conspiracy so on and
so forth and that seems to make it
particularly difficult to have sort of
critical thinking and epistemological
sound conversations with some conspiracy
theorists because whether there is
evidence or there appears to be or there
appears not to be it's all evidence of
the conspiracy so yeah I mean that
that's a very pertinent insight
psychologists have spoken about this
they've called these conspiracy theories
self-sealing that is they the conspiracy
theory has a thread to them which which
anticipates and responds to criticism so
for instance any time an academic
appears in sort of a public forum the
academic is instantly assigned or role
in the conspiracy and they're funded by
the shadowy groups that support the
conspiracy theory in and of themselves
and so in the past when Eric and I have
spoken about conspiracy theories in
public settings where described is where
funded by the Ford Foundation and we
enjoy all the access to the trilateral
commission for instance and I can assure
you like I had to move my bicycle from
outside of the shop before we have this
conversation I can assure you that I am
the furthest thing from any part of a
global economic elite to be making this
discussion but I just want I just want
to make one sort of caveat with that
discussion that definitely is have a
sort of the conspiratorial core sort of
interface with these conspiracy
narratives by the time these conspiracy
theories become public events and the
average American survey respondent is
aware of them I've actually got pretty
good experimental evidence which
suggests that those are folks with a
superficial engagement with the
conspiracy there are actually fairly
amenable to evidence so you can present
them with for instance with
you can show them pictures of Barack
Obama's birth announcement that was
contemporaneous you know that that were
that is taken from Hawaii newspaper on
the day of his birth and that turns out
to be very very effective at moving
people on this impression that Barack
Obama's birth is subject to a shadowy
conspiracy but yes when you talk about Q
for instance like Q is we're dealing
with a conspiracy and it's Mason stage
and those are folks for whom a regular
as you said epistemic engagement on a
scientific or at least fair basis
they're way too deep in the weeds there
be persuaded by that sort of evidence
one of the underlying sort of
psychological imperatives that I think
is connected to the desire to believe in
conspiracies is the idea that it's
somewhat more comforting to many people
to believe that everything is planned
and crafted and managed in a way rather
than to believe that random things
happen bad things happen we don't always
know the reason there's a huge element
of chance in how things go
number one do you agree that that is a
an element in people's belief in
conspiracies but what else
psychologically is underlying belief in
conspiracy so that turns out to be a
very important thread for the survey
evidence that we've gathered over the
last decade
where we went back and forth trying to
figure out the best ways to predict the
kinds of people who adopt one of the
panoply of possible conspiracy
narratives that are apparent in the
American political discussion at any one
moment and you've hit on something which
we found out to be a very powerful
predictor people who are anxious about
their life personally that is people who
wash vegetables when they go home when
they take them home from the market
people who lock the doors of their car
as soon as they hop in the car for a
drive across town people who manifest
those sort of anxieties and the
personalised separately people with the
mystique about American society people
who are very pessimistic
be subject to a terror attack in coming
years people who think there'll be a war
between the United States or China or
Russia people who think we're on the
verge of a recession those turn out to
be very influential predictors of
willingness to subscription to these
kind of conspiracy theories and we
suggest it's like it's tapping something
fundamental in human psychology that is
we are probably the evolutionary
descendants of those who were very
attuned to unseen threats that is on the
polyester scene after all the Bears who
were very cognizant of a rustle in the
bushes could be some predator like
waiting to pounce on our for isn't eat
them it was a very sound thing to do to
be very very cognizant of and attentive
to unseen threats as as threats to our
physical well-being there's probably a
good evolutionary story suggest why
we've selected almost threats and it's
really we like Eric and I like to think
about this as conspiracy reasoning
that's almost human psychology at its
natural state and so rather than having
an appreciation for random chance like
separate forces coming together and
resulting in horrendous things that take
place and really don't have much of a
logical explanation those are things we
have to learn and those are like we have
to sort of be but be made to be
cognizant of and attended to the
possibility for those occurrences and
absent the sort of the hard intellectual
work and natural state it's much easier
and much more natural to think of some
simplistic conspiracy narrative which
account for these separate events in one
encapsulated form the term conspiracy
theory is now being pointed to as part
of the problem by some conspiracy
theorists in other words there's this
idea that they like to say the phrase
conspiracy theory was created to make
people who question the official
narrative seem crazy or seem lacking
credibility or whatever the case may be
how can you address an issue like that
head-on or is it even worth arguing that
point uh
I mean so this is one of these
complicated things when I've done events
like this previously unbeknownst to me
I've often appeared with people who's
sort of business it is just sort of to
advance the particular conspirator sorry
but the narrative of the day and they've
insisted on things like no no I'm not a
9/11 conspiracy theorist I'm a 9/11
truther
yeah or I'm an I'm a I'm a Barack Obama
birther truther and so like those sort
of labels to me aren't that meaningful I
think Eric and I use this terminology
our research just because it's sort of
it taps into something that most
fair-minded people can see as broadly
implausible accounts of politics so if
that doesn't turn out to be that the
terminology that works for you in this
particular case that's fine and so I
think if it is the case that people get
upset by this terminology like eschew
the terminology and just look at the
nature of the story as its adherents
give it credit and there you'll see
stories that do sort of strain basic
credibility I mean I think one of the
problems you very quickly come up
against you know you mentioned at the
beginning when we were saying what
counts as conspiratorial thought what
counts as a conspiracy theory you
pointed to the lack of real evidence or
objective evidence the problem is that
the conspiracy theorist believes there's
plenty of evidence and it immediately
becomes a disagreement as to what counts
as a but it's like I've been the target
of the chemtrails conspiracy theorists
and even though there are significant
explanations of why you know what those
trails are that that follow behind an
airliner as it flies overhead it doesn't
really matter because they say no look
look look at all of this evidence and
then you're only arguing about what
counts as evidence so it seems like this
totally circular exercise in futility
well I'm guessing the people who've
appeared on your show or I've got
resumes the profile engage with you
those are people who if they are good
faith actors you sort of have to wonder
about their ability to engage unlike any
sort of scientific base
with other phenomenon and if they're bad
factors well then obviously no they have
a business interest in ginning up
anxiety and concern I'm not so sort of
equipped to provide you advice as to how
you should like become a public
intellectual like seeking to improve
public discourse I can only provide you
with indications for how the typical
American survey responded deals with
this right and there and there we can
see conspiracy theories are like you've
said they are a source of cognitive
economy and so they're not like learning
the minutiae of you know for instance
when the 9/11 conspiracy was a big thing
you know people would pull over the 9/11
report and the movement of individual
actors and everybody structural engineer
all of a sudden right exactly of course
and people stopped Wikipedia like in
degrees in like how steel flexes its
Center and a chemical engineering and so
no that does not describe how a typical
person who sort of just felt unease at
the active scene like massive terror
attacks in a major American city those
regular Americans were not becoming like
like sort of folk experts in steel and
fuel sources and sort of rust that might
be how people whom you met sort of
engaged the average American is thought
no this event seems weird and awful and
that like a small band of motivated
enemies of America could wreak huge
havoc and killed thousands of Americans
that just seems implausible to me it was
more intellectually satisfying for those
folks to believe that there was a
shadowy American conspiracy at work when
it comes to as you mentioned earlier
disabusing people of their beliefs
there's one question which Peter
Bogosian is a big advocate of it's
called the de feasibility question which
is effective with some political views
which is what evidence if I could
present it to you would change your mind
right do you think that that is a good
question for conspiracy theorists or is
it not a particularly useful one I think
that's
gosh is hard to say so let's sort of
bracket the question the folks who are
at the intellectual core of this the
folks who for whom their day-to-day
business is the propagation is
conspiracy these conspiracies I'm not
certain feasibilities writing for them
we've had some experimental success it's
just suggestive it was on a small sample
we asked folks who were adhering to
these conspiracy theories that have a
strong partisan Betty said just switch
the label so if you believe a conspiracy
theory about President Bush Obama or
President Trump make it about like the
other president and if that assails so
make make the conspiracy about
Republicans making about Democrats make
a conspiracy like Democrats making about
Republicans and if at that point if it
just something as simple as flipping the
partisan label makes you far more
circumspect about the conspiracy theory
people have some sense well gosh there's
probably a strong sort of partisan
heuristic I'm using my negative effect
towards the other side of politics to
stand in for something sort of more
rigorous appraising the evidence and
that turned out to be quite effective no
no I wouldn't be so likely to believe
this conspiracy theory about President
Trump if you told me it was about
President Obama four Democratic
respondents and that's the is to do at
least somewhat one other sort of
characteristic that I wanted to touch
base with you about is that you will
often see sort of an arbitrary focus
either on the big picture or the details
depending on which is most convenient
and what I mean by that is you'll
sometimes get a conspiracy theory and
skeptics will start picking it apart by
looking at the individual components the
micro components and saying component
one doesn't make sense component two
doesn't make sense and then when you
take apart twenty or different
components you say hey look none of it
makes sense the conspiracy theorist in
those cases will say no no you're
missing the big picture there are no way
that this broad story could be true
the inverse is also true where when you
question the bigger picture the
conspiracy theorist will focus in on
some individual unanswered questions for
example that may or may not really have
bearing on the bigger picture can you
talk about that a little bit is that
does that happen naturally does that
happen because of how people react when
put on the defensive or is that
calculated by the conspiracy theorists
so I mean it's all speculative you know
it's hard to sort of find enough of
these folks like the folks who are there
on the ground floor of these conspiracy
narratives the groups are so small for
instance when we when when conspiracy
theories have been born in particular
subreddits you can do analyses and the
folks were providing 90% of the content
95 to the content it's like a hundred
different user labels right so it's a
very very small band of folks who get
these conspiracy theories off the ground
I guess I would provide too speculative
answers to this question there's a
chance that these folks have sort of
stumbled upon the methodology that sort
of fairground
carnival guys who promised to close
readings that is you walk into a room
and I can tell you all these amazing
things about a group of strangers what
before we call cold reading right I'm
sure you like it's amazing they used the
identical psychic like style of
technology to talk for instance about a
good people one side of the room
somebody over here has a father called
Paul and the exact same rhetorical
strategies used to appear as if you are
in possession of private knowledge about
some group of people it's a very very
close and so and so it's also like that
the manuals on this and the manuals on
this are written by people who don't
believe that they have a mystical powers
they are they are using as a sort of a
carnival trick and so they're really
really impressive they're really well
done and really well-conceived they used
the same strategies when you are when
you meet resistance there are rhetorical
strategies to sort of tip to deflect the
conversation and realize like well as
you said a meeting opposition on a
particular expectation I had I can
rhetorically term is to talk about areas
where I think
I am better equipped in the folks who
have sort of risen to your level of your
prominence to talk about conspiracy
theories they either know this research
or though stumbled upon the strategy it
works for them element of this is really
unfair and a bunch of other
psychologists wrote about this in the
1960s they studied doomsday cults cults
who were comprised of folks who small
groups of people for whom the leadership
made specific predictions about the
impending doomsday next Thursday and so
infested Juran's colleagues said gosh it
must be the case that the the adherents
the core the leadership of this group
must be sort of they must be adherents
they must be believers they wouldn't
make contradictions that are sort of
readily sort of contradicted in a week's
time but instead it's the case that the
anticipation of the event failing the
group actually were stronger more
adherent to the belief more adherent to
the narratives when the predictions
failed when the prophecy failed like
because it was not maturity to affirm
the group's hard work and the aliens who
were going to attend the earth and
occasion this apocalypse understood how
much work we've been doing and and
because of because of the adherents and
beliefs that in this room they've chosen
to delay the apocalypse for a year and
that turned out to be a fantastic
selling point to the adherents and so
again I applaud you for making good
faith reasoned arguments but for the
folks who are at the absolute core the
absolute ground level of these
conspiracy theories we're dealing with a
different epistemic set of evidence and
I don't think that be responsive in the
way you anticipate yeah that's that's
that's certainly been my experience
we've been speaking with Thomas Wood
who's an assistant professor of
political science at Ohio State
University co-author of the forthcoming
book enchanted America Thomas a pleasure
speaking with you today and you too
thank you